you are watching ColdFusion TV
hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
to go go here computers are only as good
as the program that runs them that being
said programmers sometimes make mistakes
and sometimes with the most hilarious
consequences here are a few of such
competing errors the 5 glitches shown in
this video go beyond the traditional
glitches of computer games let's begin
number 5 the First National Bank of
Chicago era so given that loosely
speaking digital currency isn't actually
backed by anything and it's just a bunch
of numbers on the screen what would
actually happen if a computer put a few
more zeros at the end of your bank
statement because of a glitch imagine
taking a bank account to find out that
you now have over 900 million dollars in
there that's exactly what happened to
Sylvester Dorsey along with 825 other
customers of the First National Bank of
Chicago in May of 1996 I showed the
receipt to a friend and we just started
screaming said Dorsey the senior vice
president at First National said that
the situation was caused by a computer
programming error according to the bank
surprisingly no one actually just took
the money and ran away to a secluded
tropical island and that's probably a
good thing you see the total value of
this error cost about 764 billion
dollars and that's of course far more
than the total assets of the bank at the
time it was the largest banking error in
US history to solve the problem the
bank's froze all the accounts and
retracted the money upon realizing the
error I guess it would have been good to
be a multi-millionaire while it lasted
number 4 Windows Phone 8 assists to
insert a disk Windows Phone Microsoft's
answer to Android and the iPhone the
first version named Windows Phone 7 was
launched in October of 2010 and the next
major version Windows Phone 8 was
launched in 2012 despite being fairly
well received it wasn't all smooth
sailing some Windows Phone 8 users ran
into a pretty amusing situation Windows
would fail to start and then the screen
would show an error message which
instructed the user to insert your
Windows installation disk and restart
your computer it didn't say where to
insert the disk but somehow I think it
would have been a tight squeeze
so this is kind of weird right why would
such an arrow come upon the phone in the
first place well it's quite interesting
when you look into it the message comes
up because Windows Phone 8 is based on
the Windows NT kernel a kernel which
first came out in 1993 so for those of
you wondering a kernel is a computer
program that manages the input and
output requests from software so
basically it's the tie between the
software and the hardware the Windows NT
kernel has been used in the core of all
Windows desktop operating systems since
Windows 2000 including XP Vista 7 and 8
so as a result Windows Phone 8 sometimes
thought it was a desktop operating
system it's pretty interesting that the
legacy code still remains more than 20
years after its introduction but anyhow
I don't think phones with CD players
will ever catch on number three the Xbox
one password backdoor these days it's
not unusual for kids and their parents
to share the same console but
understandably many parents don't want
their kids playing certain games to
address this Microsoft introduced the
ability to set up an account for each
adult and child with some accounts
requiring a password to log in in March
of 2014 a five-year-old discovered that
he could get into his dad's Xbox one
account by giving the wrong password at
first prompt then entering nothing but
spaces as the second password and just
like that he was able to play all his
dad's games
what's incredibly ironic about this is
that the boy's dad is a security
researcher
so naturally when he saw his son using
his account he asked how he had gotten
the password once he found out he
reported the backdoor security risk to
Microsoft and they quickly patched it as
a gesture of gratitude Microsoft even
listed the 5 year old Christopher
wilhelm von hassel in their official
list of March 2014 security researchers
number 2 prisoners released early in
2011 California's prisons were getting
overcrowded so a decision was made to
release some low-risk prisoners
unfortunately as you could guess our
lovely computer errors stepped into play
and issued the release of a few
high-risk prisoners instead
approximately 450 inmates with a high
risk for violence were mistakenly
released along with more than a thousand
other additional prisoners presenting a
higher
of committing drug crimes property
crimes and other offenses as it turns
out the early-release program released
the prisoners under a non revocable
parole which means that they did not
have to report to a parole officer even
worse
nobody attempted to bring the prisoners
back into custody after they were
mistakenly released whoops
number one Bill Gates's windows 98 demo
fail Microsoft Windows 95
came out in the August of 1995 and The
Guardian called it the world's first
celebrity computer program it was a huge
success selling more than 40 million
copies in the first year the question
was would Windows 98
its successor be even better the world
would soon find out with a glimpse into
the software at the 1998 Comdex
convention in those days Comdex was a
huge computer trade show think of it
like CES on steroids all the tech
reporters came to see the latest
hardware and software in fact the very
first smartphone was unveiled there you
can click the screen now if you want to
know more about that or check out the
description below at Comdex 98 Microsoft
demonstrated their new beta version of
Windows 98 the event was broadcast live
on CNN and everybody was primed and
ready the stage was set and the world
was watching the demo started out well
then the time came to demonstrate
Windows 98
enhanced support for plug and play
devices a pretty big deal at the time
they plugged a scanner into the computer
and windows 98 was supposed to notice
the scanner and work with it but instead
this happened and it's gonna load in the
appropriate drivers you'll notice that
this scanner built
moving right along
lucky way we're not shipping Windows 98
absolutely absolutely as he could
imagine this was extremely embarrassing
for Microsoft but as history testifies
it didn't hurt sales all too much and
windows 98 came on to be a commercial
success with the release of Windows 10
being free and online and open beta
software becoming the norm embarrassing
live tech demos for OS releases such as
this may become a thing of the past as
we move forward so there you have it
that was a light-hearted look at five
comical computer glitches if you have
heard of anymore or have experienced any
firsthand please let me know in the
comment section anyway this has been to
go go
thanks for watching and I'll see you
again soon for the next video cheers
guys have a good one